all right so we were on the Internet all
right where are the questions where were
they
where oh these are the ones okay every
if a Republican is elected and rips up
the Iran nuclear deal what kind of
ramifications will be for the rest of
the world good question
bad I would say I would rephrase that
and say if Iran has a nuclear weapon
what are the ramifications for the rest
of the world and I think what we have
done is just allowed them clearly a
legal path to a nuclear weapon it's not
a question of if it's a question of when
and by the way but what happens to the
world when they have a hundred and fifty
billion dollars that we know a
significant part will be used to support
terrorist groups around the world that
is not a good governor you said it's a
question of when we know without the
deal the wind could be months it's legal
with the deal it's at least ten years
away how is that not better bill it's
already illegal for Iran have any type
of nuclear program what we're saying now
is we're going to legalize it and
pretend that the fact they ignored it
the first time doesn't mean they'll
ignore it the second time and in the
meantime they get a hundred and fifty
billion dollars they get a legal
anti-ballistic continental ballistic
missile program
if we don't if we don't do the deal the
sanctions go away because none of the
other country is going to do them not
only they don't know what either get a
deal or we get nothing no that's not
true the sanctions that's not true at
least they were passed by resolutions of
the Security I'm talk about the alert to
be repealed with the other countries who
are part of the sanctions you know what
Marco Rubio said we're not a planet
we're just one country all those
countries that are part of the sanctions
they're not going to acknowledge them
anymore so they're going to trade with
Iran so either we get the deal or we get
nothing no I don't think that's true if
we don't get the deal they don't get
they don't get a hundred fifty billion
dollars that you would we can use to
become B dominant not just economic
military power in the Middle East when
we know they're going to use it for
terrorist activity well yeah
period they were the number one power in
the Middle East when Nixon was president
and we loved it they were in a terrorist
state and they weren't right
one they weren't the number one right
state sponsor of terror gives whenever
we get rid of a dictator something worse
comes along yet that happens look that
happens it has happened
and we had a because they're full of
moderates okay we had a situation before
W came in where we had a number of
states that were buffers against Iran we
had a pretty good balance between the
Sunnis and the Shia's over there it's
actually balanced you had Jordan on our
side Egypt on our side the Saudis on our
side you had a sunni government in
baghdad okay what do we knocked him off
gave it to iran now we got a shia
governments right across the middle east
out who all hate us and so we did that
because of a war we started what we
started that well i just want to stand
how can you guys keep doing it wrong and
keep being so confident of anything what
did you think of what you think of
Ronald Reagan and Reykjavik in 1987
thought I made the right 20 when he
offered Gorbachev to go down to zero
zero get rid of entire nuclear arsenal
and how would that go over today with
Republicans I think it's very different
today I think it's very different
because we are even more dangerous where
where you have China you have North
Korea North Korea even if they sign some
sort of accord would never do it we know
they have coordinators estimates wait
let's go these 20 nuclear weapons but we
know other countries go back you're what
Ronald Reagan offered to get rid of our
entire nuclear arsenal what if Obama
offered that I thought that go over I
don't think it go
how would that I think it would go over
the way it should go over which is not
very well so nothing you have fo Reagan
was wrong avoids no that was a different
world and you have to look for oh really
different world Reagan business it was
you didn't have a nuclear North Korea
you didn't have what will be a nuclear
Iran you didn't have a nuclear China at
that point you sure you did China got
nuclear weapons in 1964 well alright
well you they were as much of a
challenge to America as they Kobe come
on you just love again hate Obama I mean
it's like it's never about a clear
personnel it's a question of policy
the world America was more respected it
was stronger people had greater
confidence in our future when Reagan was
present than they do today and by the
way you look at the world today there
are over 40 million refugees the largest
since the end of World War 2 that is a
tragedy and most the largely because of
about the largest numbers the largest
bill bill bill the largest numbers come
from two countries Syria and Libya Syria
is where this president addressed the
American people and said I'm drawing a
red and Syria is not stabilized because
of George Bush's stupid war in Iraq and
global Syria was destabilized Syria was
be stabilized before Isis existed and
the second is Libya and and somehow I
guess George Bush is responsible for
Libya - in fact it was is Obama the
Clinton Obama policies working with the
Italians and the French got rid of
Qaddafi right leading from behind and
one we created this void instead of
helping forces that would have been
pro-german wrong it was good when Bush
got rid of Saddam Hussein but bad when
Obama get rid of God no not at all how
can europe ian's countries assimilate
the migrants into their pluralistic
societies carefully it's going to be
it's almost impossible for them just to
find a solution they've decided to
divide all the immigrants coming in but
many countries are rejecting them but
also I mean let's be honest I mean
Mexican immigrants who come here
basically share our value system that is
not true necessarily with the immigrants
who are coming into Europe I mean I
don't know of any Mexicans who want a
theocracy but there are many Muslims who
come from theocratic societies I mean
it's very hard it's harder to assimilate
them you know who wants to hire someone
at Supercuts are wearing a burka and now
there's a problem no one wants their
hair cut by an invisible lady I think I
know that
the crisis might end now with with
winter with the winter then the number
of immigrants is going to diminish and
then the the problem right now right now
that are facing Europe is going to
dimension okay let's say Chris Matthews
there's Trump's candidacy make us look
foolish in the eyes of the world yeah a
nice soft ball about a one-word and I
don't think yet ever yes I just wanted
to make history there and I use up my
time yes things up your time you know
when we talk about the country being
worse off you know there's been a lot of
progress in this country in the last 10
or so years you know we have same-sex
marriage now we watch the Republican
debate the other night nobody fought
about that they did maybe there's
Huckabee you know you needed Marjoe
invitation right but that went over
nobody wanted to fight about Republicans
done so we go through it's better
everybody wants to talk about the
greatest generation all you know those
guys wouldn't done this stuff they
wouldn't have said it's okay to be gay
they would have said same-sex marriages
all right they would have the country's
get much better on ethnicity every one
of our kids is more liberal and
ethnicity than we are they just thought
I didn't think about it it never occurs
to them so it's just a better country I
don't know why we keep whipping
ourselves to say we're not as great as
we were the greatest generation was
wrong on so many things the services
were not integrated right right the gays
were beating up in the barracks I'm
sorry the country is better now morally
in many ways there was a raven
sure okay
does the election of Jeremy Corbyn in
the UK well he wasn't elected he was
he's head of the Labour Party okay in
the UK signal a global swing toward
populist and what that means but I could
ask another Jeremy Corbyn question he is
advocating that the UK apologise for the
Iraq war for their participation in the
Iraq war should America it was clearly a
mistake I mean in 2003 we live in the
Republican candidate we made it we made
a huge mistake and as journalist I think
it was also part of our responsibility
we were silenced and we did a challenge
it's not true yeah we did we didn't
challenge that we to yourself no no no
not that we yourself no it's the war I
think no that we doesn't work here no
we're too far the war the fact is that
I've Journal is now even challenger we
should have no otherwise they opposed to
win every time I read I did television
show and Michael Moore got it at the
Oscars
yeah I'm sure you did don't be
condescending oh no what I'm saying is
that as Joan you really don't like this
sorry we should have done much better
charlie okay bush but the challenge but
he obviously we didn't challenge him
enough because why do we order the war
but why are we all lumped together why
you know some journalists didn't Chris
and I spoke out against the war Michael
more like I was about to say stood up in
the Oscars and they all booed him but he
had the guts to say we shouldn't do this
and it's immoral and not right and there
was lots of people there was
demonstrations all around the world lots
of people were against this war
including some people in the Congress
not Hillary Clinton not 28 Democrats but
lots of people so yeah I mean okay let's
not lump no lumping okay
brock obama howard dean they all
post-award so your people okay um last
question and then i want to do my ed
solomon impression no I do because that
sullivan used to introduce people in the
audience remember that remember when he
used to do that Arnold Palmer's in the
audience hey hey gentlemen audience
tonight are the greatest comedians of
all time mr. Martin Short ladies and
gentlemen
learn short we're in the greatest
committee in zone James Brown and his
soul crap will be neck
that's Gabe Kaplan spit all right last
question can the u.s. still excuse that
China and other countries are not doing
their part on climate change no I mean
yes the climate is rotten and yeah but
you know they're trying yes they have
problems we don't and we wish they would
do it faster but I'm sure they wish we
would do it faster but this idea that I
heard at the Republican debate that you
know what other countries do bad stuff
so we shouldn't even try that's a crazy
giggling I thought America was the
leader I thought we weren't supposed to
lead from behind human technology
yeah and technology it's going to change
right it's already changing continuously
and so what we see today is not what
we're going to see in 10 years or 20
years and to think that we shouldn't
lead is ridiculous this limit let me say
as a Republican I actually think climate
change exists and I know that maybe
little and you're not alone does Harry
Paulson does Watsa and I honestly think
that America is not the problem America
is the solution we produce now 16
percent of you couldn't ask what mark is
saying is absolutely right
what we have to do is develop
technologies that allow us to
decarbonize and at the same time grow
our economy and create jobs if we simply
impose costs on America we don't help
the global so other Republicans at the
debate talk like the jobs are in coal
where solar now provides I think 10
times as many jobs as called that the
jobs in America are always in the next
endless hours exactly right because
we're going to be creating new jobs that
more than replace the jobs that are lost
what did you rate your billions in
typewriters Maureen's dream
right here what were you two here did
you hear what Henry Ford said if I'd
asked people what they wanted they would
have said a faster horse that's right
perfect way to end it thank you very
much ladies
Oh
you